european leaders are stepping up efforts
to prevent russia from invading ukraine
french president emmanuel macro is
leading a new diplomatic effort to
engage all parties in dialogue he's been
holding talks here in berlin after
meetings in kiev and moscow macau says
there's been no breakthrough but that
he's helped defuse tensions
moscow denies claiming he's planning an
attack but is continuing to amass
weapons and troops at the border with
ukraine
in the palaces of power europe's leaders
are engaging in a diplomatic push to
defuse the crisis on ukraine's borders
the leaders of germany france and poland
tried to show a united front
in berlin
our common goal is to prevent a war in
europe
the deployment of russian troops on the
border with ukraine is very worrying and
our assessment here is very much the
same as is our position
the meeting followed a diplomatic blitz
by emmanuel macron who pushed for
further talks on visits to moscow and
kiev
i believe that we have concrete
practical solutions that will allow us
to move forward
we have had the opportunity to discuss
this together
i have also had the opportunity to
discuss this with president putin as i
have done with my european partners and
several of our allies
one of those practical solutions could
be resolving a long-running conflict
within ukraine's own borders
in the eastern donbass region ukrainian
soldiers have been fighting
russian-backed separatists
over seven years ago france and germany
helped negotiate a peace deal between
ukraine the separatist forces and their
backer russia
but the ceasefire agreements the
so-called minsk accords never held
now experts think these diplomatic
channels and the minsk agreements could
be revived
but a reduction in weapons and troops
along ukraine's border and in eastern
europe looks unlikely
the kremlin denied reports that putin
told macron russia would not further
increase military tensions and pull
troops out of belarus later this month
meanwhile more planes carrying u.s
soldiers touched down in nato member
poland
while the diplomatic channels are still
open the build-up of soldiers in the
region continues
well let's talk about some of the
developments with theresa fallon
director of the center for russian
europe asia studies in brussels uh we've
heard from macau
saying that they have concrete practical
solutions that will allow them to move
forward do you have any idea what he's
talking about there
well that's quite interesting because it
seems that the kremlin has already tried
to step back what macron has said that
he got out of the kremlin so i think
that's a worrying sign uh also after he
went to kiev they both
president zielinski of ukraine and also
president macron stepped away from the
idea of the finlandization that's almost
a pejorative about trying to put ukraine
on this path maybe they did discuss this
but i think in the public domain that is
something extremely sensitive and
because of eight years of war
and 14 000 deaths in ukraine it's
actually made ukraine more pro-western
so this idea might have reached its
sell-by date uh this idea of a
finlandization of ukraine is so
sensitive because
there's also this kind of growing
nationalism in ukraine because of eight
years of war maybe these stuff should
have been taken far earlier and in
addition to that i mean putin couldn't
resist taking a little jibe at uh
president macron saying that after five
year five hours of dialogue with him it
was torture so it's kind of a mixed
message that the kremlin is sending in
regard to macron's meeting with him
what about this talk of uh proposing a
neutral status for ukraine in order to
satisfy russia's security demands what
do you make of that
as i i just mentioned that i think that
uh this is one possible off-ramp but
will the ukrainian public agree to that
and this also sends worrying messages to
both sweden and finland because they
fear that the door to nato could be
closing their status is neutral and what
will be the bigger security implications
for the region and many analysts say
that
if you give that
now to putin he will ask for more in the
region because let's remember his two uh
grand
agreements that he's asked nato and the
us
for is that all troops move out of
central and eastern europe
since 1997 any country that joined nato
so this might just be the hors d'oeuvre
to a much bigger change in the security
landscape
russia and belarus are conducting joint
drills in belarus how do you assess
this in in light of the crisis
well i think it sends an extremely
worrying message because if you look at
the map kiev is not very far at all from
belarus and in addition to that
president macron said that was one of
the things that he received from
president putin that there would be some
form of de-escalation because that's
what everyone wants to see in order to
continue dialogue but president putin
didn't really say that that would happen
he says that he's moving troops they're
doing exercises nothing to worry about
here but if you look at the strategic
map there i mean that's an incredible
pincer movement and it means that uh
perhaps belarus is far more in
moscow's orbit than other people are
comfortable with especially other
countries in the region what about the
western buildup of troops then which has
begun is that the right signal to be
sending
well right now there are about 130 000
troops that russia has put into place
the west is kind of putting in 300
troops to germany for example so i think
it's it's a sign of assurance because
these are members of nato but i think
that this doesn't even come close to
what russia is doing
teresa fallon director of the center for
russia
europe asia studies thank you very much
for being on the show appreciate it
thank you
thomas silverhorn is a member of the
german bundestag for the conservative
csu and is the parliamentary group
spokesperson for transatlantic ties
welcome
macau says we have concrete practical
solutions that will allow us to move
forward what are those solutions
our first it was high time for the
german chancellor to be in washington
and to dispel any doubts on the new
german government but clear messages we
stand united in the transatlantic
community there is a close coordination
also in details
and yes everything is at the table and
what we need now is a clear and concise
messaging towards russia in order to
bring them to the table of negotiations
what is going to bring them to the table
though what's going to get that dialogue
continuing and um
and some sort of solution found
well everything on the table means we
have to coordinate ourselves within the
transatlantic community
on very concrete steps
including economic sanctions including
the entire energy supply
including also the delivery of weapons
not every partner has to do everything
but we have to have a clear concept and
a clear messaging and yes
talking and walking have to go hand in
hand now it's been rumored that mccoy is
proposing a neutral status for ukraine
to satisfy russia's security demands
what do you make of that
we have to be aware of the fact that
putin follows a long-term strategic
vision of restoring a sort of former
former soviet union
and at this point we have to state that
there is a systemic difference between
liberal democracies and autocracy
between the western integrated countries
in the european union and nato and
russia
and here we can only state what has
already been stated in the 70s of the
last century we can only agree to
disagree at this systemic difference
but bearing in mind
those systemic
differences we have to find uh motors
with nd how to proceed and now it's up
to
the negotiating parties
to sit together and to define a concept
and an object for negotiations how to
shape
the entire security architecture but
it's not up to
any one of
the western leaders i would say
to proceed with the single proposals we
should stay united and bear in mind the
long vision the long-term vision of
russia
mr zuberhorn what would a neutral status
for ukraine actually mean though what
would that do
it's up to the ukraine to decide
for themselves where they want to go
with european
integration with democracy with the rule
of law
and russia now
sets
the entire international order at stake
if the russian concept is to dominate
its neighboring countries
to
to attack
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of neighboring countries
this is not a common ground for
negotiations so we have to strive to
stick to the international
public order and this is the core
essence of the messaging we should send
as
partners in the transatlantic community
there's certainly a lot at stake here
and so much more thomas silverhorn from
the german bundestag thank you very much
for being on the show
thank you
for more let's bring in bruno tata here
he's the deputy director of the
foundation for strategic research that's
a french independent thank tank thanks
for being with us brina multiple
diplomatic initiatives are underway to
resolve the russia ukraine crisis would
you say that france under emmanuel
macron is now the main player in leading
those efforts for europe
well not the main player but clearly
macron thought he needed to take the
initiative
i think he does not anticipate that he
will be the only leader
talking to putin and zielinski but
clearly his initiative which is to be
followed by a visit by chancellor
schultz later
in a few days
has triggered some kind of diplomatic
momentum so i would say he's been
leading the way but he's certainly not
the only
european leader who's going to play an
important role in trying to solve this
crisis
so you say momentum is now building in
these diplomatic efforts uh president
mcconn claims he received assurances
from president putin that a
de-escalation in the russia ukraine
crisis is possible now russia has been
downplaying any talk of progress what's
your reading of the outcome of mr
mcconnell's shuttle diplomacy this week
well two things first of all
there's a value in diplomacy in itself
meeting face-to-face a leader as mccoy's
done and as schultz will do
for four five six hours it has value in
itself because it allows the leaders to
better gauge each other and know each
other's attention i'm not saying that
that
as former president bush once said but
there is a value in itself in the meet
in the long meeting face-to-face second
there's a war there's a war of
communication that's a classic you would
anticipate
russia saying something like of course
we made no commitments whatsoever well i
say let's wait and see uh ishmael is
correct to say that
russia has promised to withdraw his
forces from belarus after the exercises
that are going to take place in the
coming days
then it would be very simple to uh to
verify
okay uh president macron made reference
though to concrete practical solutions
for the ukraine crisis and for
addressing russia's security concerns
what exactly
do you think he's talking about there
he's talking about two different things
you see the two separate tracks that
both france germany poland and the
united states and others are trying to
explore there's one tribe which is the
circle normandy format which is about
the implementation of the minsk two
agreements it's about the domestic
future of ukraine and according to his
credit has been uh
successful in rejuvenating a format
which everybody thought back in november
that was that it was pretty much dead so
that's the first strike the other track
is the more the broader discussion on
the so-called security architecture in
europe and this is about
arms control this is about confidence
and security building measures and
that's the discussion that's obviously
also taking place at the u.s russian
level and the nato russia
level but there's a european input in
that discussion and that's what i was
referring to is that enough to defuse
the crisis uh what do i know
it all depends of uh what
mr putin's plans are and nobody knows
what they are and i'm even sure that
mr macron does not know much more
as he returns to paris
just briefly do you see a
coherent strategy for shaping the
european security architecture between
europe the u.s and nato in a way that
would satisfy russia
well the first part of the answer to
your question is yes there is a coherent
strategies that despite what many
commentators say
uh europe and the united states france
germany and the us are pretty much on
the same page here there are nuances of
course but i don't see any significant
divergence of opinion or political
choices regarding these big issues and
that's what really matters there's
there's a unity of europe and there's a
unity of the west behind the nuances now
do we think that we can produce
options and solutions that are
acceptable both to us and to mr putin
unfortunately i don't think so and this
is where deterrence comes into play
because uh even if mr putin does not yet
hasn't yet decided to uh to embark in a
major military operation in ukraine we
have to deter him to discourage him from
thinking he could achieve meaningful
military results without suffering
extraordinary severe policies
deputy director of the foundation for
strategic research thank you very much
for talking with us
thank you
you